how's it going everybody it's Warren and
one of the biggest questions about
Avengers in game is what exactly is up
with Captain America and his ending now
before I talk about anything I must
issue a spoiler alert I am going to be
talking about major spoilers and
Avengers in game including the ending so
if you haven't seen it yet now's the
chance to click away and also if you're
new be sure to grab the subscribe button
I'm giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet and a glow-in-the-dark painting
of Thanos today is the last day to enter
so be sure to subscribe so again at the
end of this movie we see Captain America
go back in time to return all of the
Infinity stones to the points in which
they grab them from and then when hope
counts down and tries to bring him back
he doesn't come back but off by the lake
we see old man Captain America sitting
on a bench and as it turns out he of
course did not come back to the present
time instead he stayed back in the past
and lived out his life with Peggy Carter
but this raises the huge question how
did Captain America still end up in the
present time as an old man according to
Professor Hulk and the ancient one if
you go back in time and change events of
the past it does not affect the future
instead it creates an alternate timeline
so how the heck are we seen old man
Captain America in the current timeline
that we know when him going back in time
and staying there should have created an
alternate timeline well as it turns out
it did Captain America going back in
time and stayin with Peggy Carter did
create an alternate timeline and this is
coming directly from the Russo brothers
who directed the film themselves in a
recent QA when Joe Russo was asked about
Captain America's ending he said it's
not a time loop both the ancient one and
Hulk were right you can't change the
future by simply going back to the past
but it's possible to create a different
alternate future it's not butterfly
effect
every decision you made in the past
could potentially create a new timeline
for example the old cap at the end of
the movie he lived his married life in a
different universe from the main one he
had to make another jump back to the
main universe at the end to give the
shield to Sam so there you have it right
from the Russa brothers who directed the
film themselves when Captain America
went back in time he did in fact create
an alternate timeline it was not the
same present
that we saw Avengers in game play out in
instead he did create a new timeline but
simply time traveled back to the main
MCU timeline at the end of the movie to
give the shield to Sam this makes
perfect sense because it does follow the
rules of what Professor Hulk and the
ancient one did say and it covers what
everybody is calling the biggest plot
hole of the movie saying that Captain
America should not exist in this
timeline well he doesn't he simply
traveled to this timeline from his
though that is Captain America's
timeline explained by the Russo brothers
themselves to me it makes perfect sense
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below and
again last day to enter the Infinity
Gauntlet and glow-in-the-dark famous
painting by globe I bow to enter all you
have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
fluff
[Music]
[Applause]